Texas senator Ted Cruz he had the face
of a bat and the charm of a cave of bats
and he needed my help
for a job a job that few would touch
with a ten-foot American flag pole to
surveil Muslims and who was I to turn
him down I needed the work
I'd take the case and Cruz Ted Cruz for
Muslims there was no better place to
start than right here in the office
after all aj+ was al-jazeera which was
in the Middle East where there were
known Muslims who those of them who were
they fooling they were everywhere
smart productive enemies they were on to
me like an internet troll to a female
gamer I had to think bigger
I had to patrol the streets and what
better place than right across the bay
to Fremont California
you can bye kid but you can't hide there
are 250,000 Muslims in the Bay Area
alone but Fremont Fremont it was home to
the biggest Afghan population in the
United States a population that's been
practicing Islam with impunity until now
first I had to make contact
I'm with the cruise control formed
self-appointed vigilante group here in
Fremont have you seen any every day
every day mm-hmm
every single day so you are Muslim yeah
so you're religious you admit to being
religious I'm Muslim got it that was
easy
now to nail them now what did you do
this morning hello pepper don't lie to
me the middle the day guys eaten lunch
kind of suspicious did you plot anything
this morning yeah yeah I did I plotted
to take a shorter way to work what do
you study psychology psychology yeah
well I want to work with little kids oh
no sir have you seen anything radical
around here nope really okay well then
what are these alligators don't eat
marshmallows I was losing my cool
everyone seemed nice
- nice what weren't they telling me I
had to find an insider a Muslim who
would appreciate that Teddy and I just
wanted to protect them by watching their
every move
what are your thoughts on our future
president Ted Cruz's plan to surveil
Muslim communities I worry that we might
elect someone who's so out of touch with
civil rights I'm sorry what civil what
civil rights how do you spell that
see see I I I was gonna say SV her name
was Zara Billy attorney activist Muslim
I needed to prove to her that I was
helping I see that no one is out there
on the streets the way I am I'm out
there every single day I'm following
mothers around the park I mean this is
the work that we need to be doing to
keep our communities safe who else is
out there doing this people seem to
think that the Muslim community's not
already being surveilled the Obama
administration has been surveilling us
the Bush administration was surveilling
us unfortunately we have a long history
of targeting people based on their race
or religion I couldn't believe it was
this broad right had Muslims been
subjected to surveillance for years the
answer was duh
of course they had after September 11th
the NYPD started spying on muslim-owned
businesses student associations and
every mosque within a hundred miles of
New York City turned out the whole NYPD
program was bad like Bieber with
dreadlocks bad the kind of bad that led
to no credible terror leads and ended up
ostracizing Muslims for no reason and my
detective work told me this targeted
surveillance happens outside the Big
Apple to the FBI is actively piloting
secretive programs called shared
responsibility committees which seem
innocent enough like a young Miley Cyrus
but they're actually more like
present-day Miley Cyrus morally
questionable and coming in like wrecking
balls okay she had my attention all
right but then she said something that
cut me to my core going around targeting
people who just want to be involved in
their community organizations and
mosques that's the problem I don't know
if you saw but some people showed up
with guns outside of mosques all over
the country
last year that's as unamerican as it
gets was she right was I being an
American maybe Teddy didn't have all the
answers I didn't want to spy on these
people I wanted to smoke shisha with
them and talk about the new season of
empire his ideas were stale old on the
out like Tamagotchis and limp Biskit you
had it all wrong Teddy the only thing
Muslims need protection from is you